[Musique]
bien bonjour à vous tous et bonjour à
chaque à 1 par an ben non je n'ai pas
fait une en bulles même si je fais
semblant de l'être même si ça reste un
peu ma façon de me déplacer n'ont en
vérité en vérité mon vrai métier
j'étais psychologue à l'hôpital de
roanne un ici mais dans le service de
néonat à néonat ça veut dire
néonatologie c'est là que sont
accueillis les bébés soient qu'ils
soient nés trop tôt prématurément soit
qu'ils soient porteurs d'une maladie et
moi quand les bébés arrivée dans le
service je leur disais souvent
allons bon mon pauvre vieux c'est encore
des cigognes qui s'est cassé le buzz
qu'elle atterrisse âge mais ici tu vas
voir ici tout doucement on va prendre
soin de toi ici l'année au nahd ce n'est
pas la maternité c'est un service
d'urgence et de réanimation
c'est ce qu'on n'a pas souhaité c'est ce
qu'on n'a pas attendu alors moi pour me
présenter je disais que j'avais
l'habitude de dire bonjour je suis la
dame qui vient dire bonjour aux bébés au
bébé puis à leurs parents puis quand
j'avais dit ça je sautais sur mon fil de
funambule
histoire de pas prendre trop de place ne
pas encombrer les autres qui avaient
travail à faire parce que
c'est pas évident d'être psy dans un
service de réanimation et d'urgence
et je voudrais profiter de ce qu'on est
ici ce soir pour les remercier tout ce
que ces bébés eux leurs parents et lui
ce service que j'ai tenté mais parce
qu'ils m'ont permis pendant un temps
partagé des moments extraordinaires très
douloureux très beau aussi ils m'ont
aussi appris à trouver ma place juste
place dans ma vie
vous savez c'est un truc pas facile à
trouver mais bon peut-être qu'avec mes
histoires de psy de fil de funambule de
couveuse de néonat je suis en train de
mélanger les pinceaux
alors écoutez je vais vous proposer de
me suivre
on va lire néonat voilà donc j'arrive
ce jour là quand j'arrive dans le
service il y avait une agitation
inhabituelle ça allait dans tous les
sens ce n'est pas normal
alors j'ai rien dit j'ai rien fait j'ai
pas questionner pour moi c'était pas le
moment je suis allé poser mon sac voilà
dans le bureau du surveillant
peut-être parce que je ne bougeais pas
peut-être parce que je devais estiot
n'est pas un médecin qui m'a à regarder
il m'a dit annick on va avoir besoin de
toi il ya un bébé
pierrick qui est arrivé dans le service
hier soir et son état s'est aggravé et
maintenant il faut qu'on bute sur lyon
les parents sont furieux sont rendus
hors d'eux et
chacun en a pris pour son grade dans le
service aux nié tout se passait tirez
pas les voir toi alors ça je sais que ça
fait partie de mon métier désamorcer les
colères jours sourit les pauvres j'aime
bien et puis je vais en salle des
couveuses voilà alors salle des
couveuses commence par se harnacher
comme les infirmières je mets mon
sarraut mais voilà
à 9,9 boîte en verre
ça s'appelle des couveuses 9 boîte sur
des roues avec des écrans et à
l'intérieur des neuf boîte de verre 9
petit tout petit bébé et de part et
d'autre d'une couveuse deux infirmières
l'une brune et l'autre blonde et là je
comprends qu'elles sont en train de
prendre soin de ce bébé là pierrick
alors je prends mon souffle
je lance mon fils je saute sur mon fil
de funambule
je me penche pour le regarder et je le
vois tout petit si petit avec son petit
kilo boîte de sucre
je le vois grille plus que gris avec les
yeux comme en français par deux coups de
poing je vois sa respiration qui est
cadencé par le respirateur c'est dur ces
gens me disent en raid ses bras à rennes
aussi replié alors je dis bonjour
pierrick je suis à dame qui vient dire
bonjour aux bébés le docteur m'a dit que
tu as beaucoup de mal pour respirer et
on attend le cinq mutuelles à lyon où on
soigne les bébés mais là il ya brunes et
blondes elles prennent soin de toi et
moi je vais aller parler à ton papa ya
ta maman à ce moment là une voie au
dessus de moi c'est brune elle me dit du
v comme tu veux moi je te conseille pas
alors je quitte des yeux pire est qu'il
regarde et je vois brune brune qui est
une puéricultrice que j'aime beaucoup
ans que j'ai tout à fait confiance
quelqu'un qui est posée qui a du métier
je vois les larmes qui roulent sur ses
joues me dit j'ai pris une de ces
chasses bon et là je me dis toujours sur
mon fils qu'est-ce qui a besoin de moi
les parents avec leur colère les deux
infirmières qui sont déstabilisés par la
colère qu'elles ont reçues ou le bébé en
détresse
aspire à thouars et à ce moment là
j'entends blonde qui des abruzzes il est
encombré il faut les spires et vite
je le regarde un peu mieux et je vois
que ses lèvres sont devenus noirs qui à
de la mousse qui sort de sa bouche et la
mousse elle moussel moussel l'ample elle
enfle alors là il n'y a plus de question
à se poser c'est lui qui a besoin de moi
c'est lui qui a besoin de nous tous
réunis autour de lui
c'est là bas juste place
je vais vous dire c'est pas facile de
rester auprès des bébés qui va mourir
c'est pas la meilleure des places on en
a pas envie mais c'est justement parce
qu'on n'a pas envie de cela juste deux
places alors je m'accroche à moi les
mains dans le dos je reste là et à ce
moment derrière fond de la salle une
porte s'ouvre et un couple apparaît et
la jeune femme la voix bourrue grognon
pas contente elle des bons alors aux bus
rentrait maintenant un psycho de service
je me présente maladroitement à tous les
coups le pape a dit ah ouais psychologue
et il tourne ostensiblement le dos la
maman un peu plus affable elle me dit
vous savez on n'a rien contre vous rien
mais et alors là je vais vous dire tout
y passe le gynécologue est premier suivi
la grossesse l'accouchement prématuré
très prématuré dans l'urgence la
mutation dans un autre hôpital
la mutation dans notre hôpital hier soir
et la nouvelle mutation qui se prépare
et il en rajoute et moi par dessus les
épaules des parents qui se sont adossés
la couveuse pour me parler
moi je vois pierrick grille plus que
gris et la mousse qui enfle qui ronfle
autour de sa bouche
je sens brune et blonde redhead tendue
très inquiète
ce qui va arriver
alors je me dis mais la colère est en
train d'envahir la salle des couveuses
l'a envahi le service et dans cette
colère on a laissé tomber pire et qu'on
le voit plus il va en mourir cet enfant
est il comme de la moutarde qui
mentonnais je me dis moi il faut que je
me rassemble tous donc je prends mon
souffle et ostensiblement je lâche les
parents de mon regard pour regarder leur
bébé et eux ils suivent mes yeux
et enfin enfin il voit celui que je
regarde leurs enfants alors je dit d'une
voix un peu forte parce que des fois les
bébés font semblant d'être dur de la
feuille jeudi pierrick et quand je dis
ça les yeux du bébé comme à chaque fois
les yeux du bébé se tourner vers la voie
qui s'adresse à lui par son prénom
pierrick tu n'es pas seul pierrick à ton
papa pierrick à ta maman qui a brûlé
blonde est en train de soigner le samu
est arrivé je n'ai rien dit d'autre
je voulais simplement réunir tout le
monde autour de pierrick ç'a duré très
longtemps
et puis puis j'ai vu le papa qui avance
et il a ouvert la porte aux pieds la
couveuse et la passe et sa grande main
dans la couveuse et la caresser la
petite jambes redresser sa main et alors
j'ai vu le petit pied avec ses orteils
qui pianote et la grosse paume de main
j'ai vu la maman qui faisait le tour de
la couveuse aussi et qui ouvrait une
petite porte à la tête et elle a passé
ses deux mains elle a pris la main du
bébé dans ses mains elle à caresser
doucement et moi sur mon fils je
regardais je disais piano à quatre mains
lui main dans une seule dans une
couveuse
4 qui savent les gestes pour sauver et 4
kg aux ceux de la tendresse
là encore c'est dur et longtemps très
longtemps
et puis il faut me croire
j'ai vu la mousse qui rentrait dans la
bouche
j'ai vu qu'il n'y avait plus de mousse
j'ai vu un petit pois roses au creux des
choux et le petit pois est devenu petit
rond et le petit rond a envahi le visage
et le rose est redescendu tout le long
du corps jusqu'au plus petit orteil et
alors là là inégalée drire
j'ai entendu ma voix et je n'ai été
donnée j'ai dit denis l'audois mon vieux
tu aime les câlins et puis tombe abrite
à maman ils savent les données j'étais
heureuse pouvait pas savoir
parce que là là nous avions tous si
trouvé notre juste place et la mort
était en train de partir
le samu pouvait arriver pierrick aller
vivre je vous raconte pas ce que c'est
arrivé à 10 ans le numérique va très
bien j'ai quitté la salle des couveuses
j'ai roulé mon fils d'un ma poche et de
coureurs et coureuses de berceau au
berceau je suis allé voir les autres
bébés du service je vous ai raconté
cette histoire parce que c'est une parmi
toutes les histoires qui m'ont beaucoup
touché de ce qui se passait dans cette
néonat précieuse mais vous savez cette
histoire de juste place qui est une
histoire tellement importante à trouver
dans nos vies j'ai trouvé à tâtons parce
que le service m'a aidé et je les
trouvais aussi parce que quand même j'ai
pas pris mon métier tout seul ce sont
des psychanalystes qui m'ont appris mon
métier et en particulier
je viens vague qui est une psychanalyste
et elle illustre souvent les théories
qu'elle élabore les illustres avec des
oeuvres d'art et donc pour m'aider à
trouver la juste place j'ai pris appui
sur ce tableau de léonard de vinci
décidément il est à l'honneur ce soir
mais c'est un grand monsieur alors le
tableau c'est sainte anne la vierge et
l'enfant jésus
voilà on va le regarder ensemble vous
savez que dans ce temps là les artistes
prenait souvent leur inspiration soit
dans la mythologie soit dans la religion
on peut imaginer mais c'est pas sûr on
peut imaginer que léonard de vinci à son
insu dans ce tableau a représenté le
bébé qu'il avait été un petit enfant
heureux et aimé choyé par une jeune
belle mère qui avait 16 ans comme marie
dans la bible et par la mère de sa belle
mère qui était une femme encore jeune a
enfin une veille dame de 40 ans quoi on
va dire et pour la petite histoire ces
dames mais l'été potier et sans doute
c'est elle qui a donné à léonard de
vinci le goût de l'art bon alors si nous
regardons ce tableau on va partir d'en
bas en bas au premier plan on voit un
bambin brad et moi ce petit garçon il
n'a pas un an
il n'a pas l'âge de marché et pourtant
ils savent ordures à escalader un petit
mouton
regardez mieux ce n'est pas un mouton il
a des petites cornes
c'est un bélier le bébé joue avec un
bélier au second plan derrière lui se
trouve marie sa mère rien hélas bien
elle s'est assise
elle a pris appui sur les genoux de sa
mère pour s'occuper de son enfant et
elle est penché en avant
regardez la bien elle ne le tient pas
elle le soutient légèrement pour le
laisser libre de ses mouvements
regardez son visage il est drôle et
souriant elle invite à oser le troisième
plan en arrière c'est anne alors j'aime
bien monsieur rappelle annick cn la mer
de la mer et regardez la bien anne elle
ne regarde pas le petit enfant
ce qu'elle regarde c'est sa fille quand
même culotté la jeune maman qui laisse
un enfant de 8 10 mois jouer avec un
bélier meehan à l'arrière-plan
elle se positionne solidement ça fait
son petit fils sont en sécurité sous son
regard bienveillant et elle sourit avec
sûrement un certain bonheur elle doit
être fier de sa petite marie devenue une
jeune maman mais à elle même regardez
bien un an elle a pris 1 puis elle aussi
sur quelque chose pas sur quelqu'un sur
quelque chose
elle a pris appui sur les montagnes sur
le dur des montagnes voilà ça c'est pour
le tableau de léonard de vinci
alors je pense que si geneviève haye a
choisi ce tableau pour illustrer ce
qu'elle a appelé du coup la fonction
sainte anne c'est pour plusieurs raisons
ce tableau comme bien des tableaux de
léonard-de-vinci voyez il est construit
en forme de triangle la tête du triangle
c'est aussi la tête de sainte anne la
tête c'est comme une partie qui aident à
penser et le bas du triangle
ce sont ces pierres garder les pieds qui
sont au bas la peinture les pieds c'est
la solide assise sur jol donc anne tout
un état à l'arrière elle est celle qui
va porter rendre solide la construction
regardez la bien elle ne parle pas ne
commente pas ne juge pas elle ne dit
rien elle soutient simplement elle donne
confiance
voilà et du coup la fille aux laisser
son enfant découvrir le monde
voilà on a un jeu de poupées russes au
troisième plan donc sainte-anne
bienveillante souriante qui va imprégner
ce caractère là toute la peinture un
côté marie bienveillante souriante et un
côté le bambin dont on peut penser qu'il
va devenir souriant bienveillant je
crois que j'ai entendu dire que léonard
de vinci tu es quelqu'un de plutôt doux
de caractère ce qui va bien avec le
reste de l'histoire et les montagnes du
mois les montagnes ne faut pas qu'on les
oublie parce que c'est notre
arrière-plan à vous et à moi
les montagnes et bien moi c'était mon
cadre professionnel c'est-à-dire mon
institution hôpital c'était le service
de néonat c'était aussi toutes ces
théories psychanalytiques qui m'ont
portée qui m'ont aidé dans mon travail
c'est ça aussi qui aide la fonction
sainte anne ce positionnement là alors
on va le regarder encore ensemble ce
tableau où ce que vous aimeriez être est
ce que vous aimeriez être le petit
enfant premier plan un enfant heureux de
grandir se développer avec des parents
bienveillants
est ce que vous seriez être cette maman
qui a quelqu'un de solide dirait
quelqu'un ressources aujourd'hui sur qui
prendra puis pour élever son enfant ou
est-ce que vous aimeriez être and à
l'arrière-plan en position un peuple
ainsi je reprends les mots de denrées
simple à l'arrière mais qui soutient et
qui permet que tout cela puisse exister
c'est ça la fonction sainte anne c'est
ce qui est devenu le fil devant
funambule
mais alors dites-moi la juste place
où est elle où est elle alors est-ce que
nous allons la mettre sur le devant de
la scène
regardez moi moi je sais moi je suis
belle je suis intelligente
celui qui est en face vous imaginez bien
il va juste se barbé s'ennuyer c'est
fini est-ce que vous avez le mettre au
centre de la scène et bien les idées de
moi comment vous faites madame si vous
savez élever votre enfant dites moi
monsieur le contremaître comment vous
faites avec votre équipe
celui qui est devant eh bien il se sent
mauvais élèves
motus et bouche cousue semelles de plomb
ils bougent plus il ya encore une autre
place au fond style pots de fleurs je
vous regarde et l'autre il va s'étioler
se ratatiner pourra rien faire alors les
juste place eh bien il n'existe pas ou
alors on pourrait dire que la juste
place serait comme un pas de danse
quelque chose où l'on se déplace de
façon à permettre à l'autre de se
déplacer et de trouver lui aussi sa
juste place au bon moment et voyez je le
tangue et notre place elle varie suivant
de tucson d'un moment l'époque notre âge
voyez mais le danseur le danseur il lui
faut apprendre à prendre très peu de
place pour de prendre la place de
personne
ce très peu de places est passée juste
fils juste mon fil de funambule
voilà tout simplement lors ce fils vous
le voulez vous voulez que je vous le
donne je vous le donne
je le lance mais fait l'effort de
l'attraper l'état vous
[Musique]